this week 48 Hours investigates The
Disappearance of a Wisconsin couple in
July 2021 Bart and Krista halderson
mysteriously vanished their 23 year old
son told police they never returned from
a trip to their family cabin 48 Hours
correspondent Aaron Moriarty
investigates how a clue on the social
media app's Snapchat led to a stunning
discovery
this is doorbell camera footage of 23
year old Chandler Alderson going house
to house asking if anyone had seen or
heard from his parents kind of difficult
Chandler told police his mom and dad
Barton Krista had gone to the family
cabin in northern Wisconsin for the July
4th holiday weekend and never returned
Sheriff's detectives Brian shonk and
Sabrina Sims visited the halderson home
so when you first got there who was home
it was just Chandler Chandler was a
college student telling friends he had
landed a job with Elon Musk company
SpaceX
we're walking around the house with him
he's pointing out things at the house
things that were missing that his
parents took when they traveled to the
cabin
why would they not call why wouldn't
there be a text or something Barbie
Townsend is Krista halderson's cousin
did you think possibly they've been in a
car accident and just hadn't been found
I thought about that or I did think
about the boat did something happen out
on the lake you know your mind just
starts to go down really murky Trails
because you're trying to figure out
what's going on so deputies headed to
the family cabin a three-hour Drive
North
Sheriff's Office anybody outside now
it's your presence make yourselves known
but the cabin was dark and empty there
were no signs of Krista and Bart
and then detectives got a break
turns out Chandler's girlfriend had been
tracking his location on the social
media app Snapchat during the time his
parents were missing and she spotted
Chandler whom she called hubby at a
remote location near the Wisconsin River
no way I would have ever guessed what
was about to be revealed never
whoa wow this actually this case is
haunting I think that when people see
the report it will stay with them for a
long time because it has really bothered
us why was this screenshot from Snapchat
so crucial well because investigators
have very little to go on I mean this
was a couple they seemingly had no
marital problems they had no financial
problems and then they vanished their
car was in the garage when you called
them it just went to voicemail
um they they worked they didn't take any
money out of the bank I mean they
literally vanished so if investigators
couldn't track their whereabouts they
would track the one person who had seen
them last which was their youngest son
why was the girlfriend tracking Chandler
did she not well she didn't trust him
because he was pretty popular with women
and he had gone out with other women and
you know with Snapchat you realize that
you could message someone and track
their location at the same time so the
only way she would continue dating him
was if he allowed that and and it just
when the police asked her she had no
idea what was on her phone and when the
police asked her to if they could
download it that's where they found it
and it really did Crack the Case in a
very very sad upsetting way Aaron cannot
wait to watch this thank you and don't
forget you can watch Aaron's report the
Snapchat clue on 48 hours tomorrow night
at 10 9 Central right here on CBS and
Paramount Plus